Hallo, guten Tag. Lale ist mein Name und ich bin zuständiger Arzt.
Kannst du noch mal Ihren Nachnamen sagen?
Lale ist meine Name.
Hallo, Herr Land. Schönen Tag.
Und wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich bin heute zu Ihnen gekommen, weil ich tatsächlich seit einiger Zeit
eine Gelbderbung der Haut und der Augen habe.
Und das hat mir Sorgen gemacht.
Deswegen wollte ich einfach vorbeischauen, ob Sie mir helfen können.
Okay, und jetzt würde ich gerne einfach zu Ihnen
ein paar Sonnenfragen und dann können Sie bitte,
ich heiße Ihnen die Erster.
Mein Name ist Krebs. Peter Krebs.
Krebs.
Wie, K, R, I, B und S.
Genau, K wie Konrad, R wie Richard, I, W, E, Mil, B wie Bertha,
S wie Sie, Fried.
Okay, Herr Krebs.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin genau 50 Jahre alt geworden, dies Jahr.
Ja, ich bin am 4. Januar 1973 geworden.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Januar 1973.
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m groß.
Und wiege knapp 80 kg.
Ja, was willst du?
Ja, wie ich schon gerade gesagt habe, ich habe tatsächlich seit
einiger Zeit habe ich eine Gelbfärbung in meiner Augen gemerkt
und meine Frau sagte auch, dass ich mein Körper gelb,
dass mein Körper gelb aussehe.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr schlecht.
Können Sie vielleicht das Mikrofon näherstellen?
Ja, ich weiß.
Es ist etwas...
Okay, Sie haben gesagt einigen Tagen, ja, Gelbfärbung,
ich habe schon bemerkt.
Genau, ich habe das selber im Spiegel bemerkt,
aber meine Frau sagt auch, dass mein Körper gelb aussehe.
Das habe ich jetzt selber nicht bemerkt,
aber deswegen bin ich ein bisschen besorgt.
Ich wollte es mal nicht vorstellen.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Also ich habe generell Rückenschmerzen,
aber jetzt wegen dieser Gelbfärbung haben ich keine Schmerzen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, dass Sie irgendwie eine Lebererkrankung haben?
Also mir ist keine Lebererkrankung bekannt.
Nein, ich bin eigentlich...
bis auf meine Rückenschmerzen habe ich keine Probleme.
Sie sind kein gesund eigentlich ohne diese Ganzverwaltung.
Liebete?
Sie sind kein gesund.
Okay, Sie...
Ich wiederhole nochmal, ich habe eine Gelbfärbung in meinen Augen bemerkt
und meine Frau sagt auch, dass mein Körper gelb aussehe.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Mischwerden?
Seit einigen Tagen haben Sie es schon gesagt, aber können Sie etwas bestimmen?
Ja.
Seit fünf Tagen habe ich das bemerkt mit meinen Augen
und jetzt sagt meine Frau halt auch, du musst jetzt mal zum Arzt gehen,
da musst du ja irgendwo sein.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon mal in eine Vorsorgeurteilsuchung schon gewesen?
Also ich war letztes Jahr bei meinem Hausarzt gewesen
und da haben wir nochmal meine Medikamente besprochen,
aber ansonsten hat er mir gut aufgenommen
und hat mich zweiteres gesagt.
Okay.
Und schon mal ein Ursprach-Untersuchung schon gehabt,
ein Bauch-Ursprach-Untersuchung.
Ja, schon Jahre her.
Schon Jahre her.
Und das war alles normal.
Ich glaube schon, ich erinnere mich gar nicht mehr so richtig daran.
Ich glaube, das war alles in Ordnung.
Da hatte ich Probleme in meiner Niere gehabt
und da hatte der Hausarzt mal ein Ursprach-Schein gemacht,
aber glaube ich, das war okay gewesen.
Okay.
Und ja, haben Sie schon in letzter Zeit ungewollt abgenommen
oder zurückgenommen?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Es mir jetzt noch nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe ja so ein bisschen zugenommen.
Wie viel Kübre haben Sie schon gemäßt?
Hab ich nicht gewogen.
Ich wiege normalerweise ungefähr 280 Stühle oder so.
Ich habe es aber nicht gewogen.
Noch mal.
Okay.
Und haben Sie ein Feber, ein Landschweiß-Arztbruch
oder so ein bisschen?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Also, mir ist nur ein bisschen aufgefallen,
dass ich jetzt seit ungefähr 1,5 Wochen
ein bisschen müde bin tatsächlich.
Also, ich bin nicht mehr so belastbar wie vorher.
Ich habe das Gefühl.
Okay.
Und ja, welche Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Erkrankungen, wie meinen Sie das?
Ja, ich meine, ja, Sie haben schon erwähnt,
dass Sie wegen einer Niere ein Problem haben beim Arzt gewesen.
Ja, das war Jahre her, das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Also, das habe ich keine Beschwerden,
weil da hatte ich damals Probleme gehabt.
Das war, weiß ich nicht, vor 15, 20 Jahren gewesen oder so.
Also, ich habe eigentlich aktuell,
habe ich Rückenschmerzen,
weil ich Medikamente fahre.
Mein Hausarzt sagte mir,
dass ich irgendein Gehüttenkolosterin hätte
und mir einen Kolosterin-Medikament dafür ein.
Und mir ein bisschen etwas für meine Psyche ein.
Also, weil es mir manchmal psychisch nicht gut geht,
hatte mir ein bisschen Angstgefühle habe,
hatte mir ein Antidepressivum aufgeschrieben.
Und ansonsten, ja,
Blutfrochdruck oder Blutzkönigangheit haben Sie das ja nicht?
Nee, das möchte ich auch nicht haben.
Danke.
Okay.
Und wegen medikamenter Einnahmen,
weiß ich, medikamenter nehmen Sie.
Ich habe mich auch nicht mitgegeben,
dass ich eine Medikamente habe.
Aber mit dem Medikament nehmen Sie.
Also, ich nehme eine Ibuprofen ein.
Mit meiner Rückenschmerzen.
Ja, ich habe einen Wandschirmvorfall.
Und dann nehme ich auch ein Paracetamol ein.
Das nehme ich schon jeden Tag eigentlich ein.
Das hilft mir auch ganz gut.
Und jeden Tag nur eine bekommen Sie?
Nee, ich nehme Ibuprofen,
zwei bis drei Mal.
Paracetamol, je nach Beschwerden,
wenn Ibuprofen nicht hilft,
nämlich zusätzlich eine Paracetamol ein.
Und diese Ibupablette,
wie viel Medikament? 400 oder 600?
Nee, 600. Ich habe mir mein Haushaltsauf.
Okay.
Und für Ihre Kolesterolinwerte
nehmen Sie auch,
ja, da nehme ich jetzt seit ungefähr 6 Monaten,
nämlich Ahtovastatin ein.
40 Milligramm.
60 Milligramm.
40.
Und einmal pro Tag.
Genau, einmal abends.
Einmal abends.
Okay.
Und ja, sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Ich bin nicht operiert worden.
Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Und ja, rachen Sie?
Ich habe aufgehört.
Vor ungefähr 10 Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Ich habe 20 Jahre geraucht.
Und dann habe ich aufgehört.
Okay. Seit 10 Jahren sind Sie schon...
Nicht mehr auch.
Ja, nicht raucher.
Und in diesem 20 Jahr,
wie viel haben Sie schon geraucht?
Das war nicht viel, weil ich nicht...
5 bis 10 Zigaretten am Tag vielleicht.
Okay. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal.
Ja, hauptsächlich am Wochenende.
Jedes Wochenende?
Ja, fast jedes Wochenende ein bisschen.
Fast jedes Wochenende.
Und wie viel?
Und was trinken Sie?
Es kommt meistens Bein, Bier natürlich.
Und ja, es kommt immer noch von der Gesellschaft.
Manchmal kann es auch ein bisschen hochprozentrieren sein.
Okay.
Und ja, das ist ja ein, zwei Flasche, oder?
Ja.
Ja, was meinen Sie? Bier oder Wein?
Ja, beide.
Weil Wein nicht eine ganze Flasche, ne?
Eine halbe vielleicht, ja.
Wir schon ein, zwei Flaschen.
Unsichheit.
Und haben Sie Erfahrung mit dem Drocken?
Ja.
Ich nehme keine Drogen.
Das ist eine regelmäßige Frage für uns.
Nehmen Sie die, dass Sie nicht persönlich.
Ach so, okay, ne. Ich nehme keine Drogen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Allaki?
Nicht bekannt.
Und sind Ihre Eltern schon am Leben?
Sie, meine Mutter ist verstorben.
Aufgrund deines Schlaganfalls, letztes Jahr.
Und mein Vater, der lebt noch, der ist dement und lässt im Alter sein.
Bei Ihrem Vater gibt es bekannt,
der auch eine andere Erkrankung?
Er nimmt Medikamente ein, aber ich stammt gegen Gutdruck.
Gegen Zucker nimmt er etwas ein.
Ansonsten nimmt er etwas für die Demenz ein.
Er nimmt etwas für die Prost-Batter ein.
Und ja, mehr weiß ich nicht.
Arbeiten Sie?
Ich bin berufstätig.
Ich bin Maschinenführer in einer Firma.
Und wie arbeiten Sie Ihre Arbeit stressig?
Der übliche Stress, aber ich bin in Schichtarbeit.
Also ich arbeite Frühschicht, Spätschicht, Nachtschicht.
Und ich mache das aber schon seit über 25 Jahren.
Und ich bin eigentlich so zufrieden.
Ich bin immer stressig.
Überall gibt es Stress.
Ja, wir haben recht.
Und ja, schon ein paar Fragen für Ihre Beschwerden.
Soll ich auch fragen, diese Geldverfälbung,
haben Sie schon mal Frühjahr gehabt oder das ist erst mal?
Das erste Mal, dass ich es habe.
Haben Sie schon etwas dagegen gemacht?
Die Geldverfälbung?
Ja.
Was kann man da machen?
Ich weiß auch.
Zum Arzt gehen?
Nein, deswegen bin ich jetzt hier.
Ich bin heute am Sonntag.
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Okay, das ist Ihre erste Arztbesuch?
Genau.
Okay.
Ich habe schon.
An meiner Frage schon gestellt und wenn Sie Fragen haben,
kann ich gerne antworten.
Was habe ich dann?
Ja, oder wenn Sie etwas hinzufügen,
kann ich gerne hören.
Sie müssen fragen, ich muss antworten.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mache.
Soll ich wieder nach Hause gehen?
Oder was mache ich jetzt?
Ja, jetzt.
Ja, ich würde.
Diagnose sollen Sie erst mal hier bleiben,
damit wir die bestimmte Diagnose hier klären können.
Was habe ich denn?
Wissen Sie denn, was ich habe?
Normalerweise, diese Geldverfälbung kommt bei,
ja, eine Wert von Bullut ist schon erhöht sein.
Das, diese Geldverfälbung, das nennen wir als Lirubin.
Meinst du, das ist eine Endproduktion von
unserer Blutköpfung, wenn zerstört ist.
Also habe ich eine Bluterkrankung?
Kann auch sein, aber auch diese kommt auch manchmal
Lebererkrankungen auch.
Wenn man Lebererkrankungen hat oder diese Gallen belasen,
die schon irgendwie kaputt ist, dann können Sie auch
diese Geldverfälbung haben.
Deshalb sollen wir erst ein paar Diagnostik hier machen.
Und ich jetzt würde gern einen Bullut abnehmen.
Kann es sein, dass ich Krebs habe?
Am schlippsten Fall, ja, das ist möglich.
Das ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Ich habe Krebs?
Ja, jetzt, das können wir nicht so sagen.
Aber erst mal sollen wir die einfache Dinge klären.
Und danach, wenn sie am schlippsten Fall, ja, das ist auch...
Ich habe Kinder, ich habe Kinder.
Ich habe Kinder, ich bin noch jung.
Ja, ich kann, ja, wir sind hier ein Gutesrum.
Und ja, hier machen wir alles, was wir machen müssen.
Soll ich lieber in den Andernskrank rausgehen?
Ich empfehle jetzt, dass Sie erst hier bleiben
und die erste diagnostische Massnahmen hier wahrnehmen können.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt?
Jetzt eine Bullutuntersuchung machen wir
und danach einige Bildgebende verfahren können wir auch...
Was heißt das Bildgebend?
Ja, das nennen wir am schlippsten Fall
oder am Ende dieser diagnostische Fall gehen.
Das nennen wir RRCP oder MRCP.
Die beiden, mit den beiden können wir die Gallenblasen weg
oder Gallenwege können wir sehen mit diesen Untersuchungen.
Also Sie nehmen mir jetzt Blut ab und dann machen Sie eine sogenannte MRCP direkt.
Ja.
Okay, okay, machen Sie das?
Selber nicht, aber ich war ja nicht immer dabei.
Und das macht man auch Sonntags jetzt oder im Krankenhaus?
Ja, das bleiben Sie hier und danach morgen früh das können wir vereinbaren.
Morgen früh und das muss gemacht werden?
Oder gibt es da nicht andere Methode, die machen?
Ja, als mal Blutuntersuchung, auch nicht.
Bauchuntersuchung, eine Untersuchung.
Okay, ja, okay.
Das ist das, was der Haushaltsverband mir gemacht hat damals, oder?
Ja, wie genau?
Eine Bauchaufnahme machen wir auch hier.
Okay, verstanden, alles klar.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen und andere Fragen?
Ja, da gibt es ein paar Fragen, der fehlt noch.
Wie ist das für Thul, Urin, haben Sie Provetis?
Nein, unsere Provetis über den Ektorus, wir haben noch nicht gesteckt.
Ja, also ich habe tatsächlich bemerkt, dass mein Stuhl heller geworden ist.
Urin?
Urin dunkel, also dunkel als sonst.
You Christ?
Jetzt wo Sie so Fragen, ja, hier so ein Oberkörper ein bisschen, habe ich das auch.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, habe ich eben geantwortet, nein.
Im Status?
Im Status, bei letztes Jahr hat mein Haushaltsausschuss kontrolliert, das wäre alles in Ordnung gewesen, alles aktuell.
Allergie und Unverträglichkeit hat gefragt?
Ja, ich habe keine Allergie.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit ein bisschen weniger, aber ich habe auch irgendwie zugenommen, ich weiß gar nicht warum.
Ihre Verwandtschaft oder Ihr Kollegen, ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Meine Frau hat mir nur gesagt, dass es bei ihr im bekannten Kreis wohl jemanden gab, der Leberkrebs gehabt hat, deswegen bin ich heute hier.
Letztes zwei Monate haben Sie irgendein Reis?
Nein, ich wein nicht im Ausland, war ich nicht.
Noch eine Frage, seit wann nehmen Sie Parastamol ein?
Ja, das nehme ich schon seit etwas längerer Zeit ein.
Also ich habe berühmt mich schwer, z.B. im Hauptsächlich Ibuprofen ein.
Und wenn das sich ausreicht wegen meinem Bandschirm vorvolle, dann nehme ich manchmal auch Parastamol ein.
In der letzten Zeit etwas häufiger als sonst.
Also ungefähr, kann es sein 3-4 Jahre?
Ach so, meinen Sie das?
Nee, nicht so lange, so ein Jahr vielleicht.
Sie haben gesagt, vor neun Monaten Kulistrioleime gestattet?
Genau, ich war bei meinem Hausarzt für den Checkup, habe ich mich vorgestellt.
Und er hat mir dann im Boot abgenommen, hat dann gesehen, als ich eine höhere Skolesterin habe und hat mir dann ein Atorvastatin aufgeschrieben.
Und er hat mir zusätzlich, habe ich ihm vergessen zu sagen, oder sie haben sich mitbekommen, wegen meinen Angstzustand, sehr trahlien aufgeschrieben.
Herr Trahlin.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Morgen schon abends, nämlich das jetzt ein 50 Milligramm.
Noch andere Fragen, Herr Leiden?
Danke, wie er an, Leide.
Ja.
Hallo, Herr Obatz.
Und wenn Sie Zeit haben, ich würde gerne ein Patient vorstellen.
Gerne, bitte schön.
Und Herr Krebs, 50 Jahre altiges Patient,
ja, steilte sich vor wegen seit fünf Tagen bestehenden Icterus und
eine zusätzlich berichtete, berichtete eine Schutul und
Schutul, heller Schutul und ja, dunkler Wasserlasten, dunkler Urinsstatus und
eine dunkle Verfärbung des Urins.
Und ja, er berichtet, dass er in der letzten Zeit ein bisschen zugenommen habe und
ein bisschen Leistungsknick, ja, aber bei der Vorsageuruntersuchung gibt es bestimmt Dinge bei der Lebererkrankungen oder wegen der Lebererkrankungen gibt es keine
bestimmte Auffälligkeiten. Und ja, Herr Krebs leidet an die Epidemie in die Atorvastatin 40 Milligramm seit sechs Monaten behandelt und wegen seiner Angststöße,
die er in der Erkrankung hat, dass er in der Erkrankung nicht mehr in der Erkrankung ist.
Und wegen seiner Angststörung bekommt er regelmäßig seit drei Tagen 50 Milligramm abends und morgens und abends und wegen
seinem Bandschieben vor Fall bekommt er zwei, drei Tabletten überprüfen am Tag und wenn die Schmerzen nicht beruhigen, dann bekommt er zusätzlich 100 Milligramm
vor der Operation, kein bekannte Allergie und in der Familienanalyse gibt es ja, sein Mutter seifend, einen Opoplex gestorben und
sein Vater leidet unter Demenz und bekannte Blutdruck und der Bedismellitus und Atelier lehipatronie und er arbeitet als Maschenführer,
ganz normalen Stressbedingungen bei der Arbeit schon bei der Patientangegeben.
Und so verdachtdiagnostisch, das spricht für eine Collangialityasis oder eine Collangitis auch, kann sein.
Collangitis passt eher nicht, er hat keinen Fieber, keinen Schmerzen auch, nicht berichtet.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Und auch nicht Schmerzen und auch noch Fieber.
Also ich würde eher sagen, er hat einen unklaren Iktorus.
Und wir müssen jetzt herausbinden, warum er diesen Iktorus hat.
Was machen wir denn mit den Patienten?
Ja, ich würde jetzt völlig untersuchen.
Ich suche irgendwie einen galen, berückschmerzten oder ja, das kann man auch Merfels bezahlen.
Und zusätzlich nehme ich Blut ab und besonders bilirubinwarte für uns, direkt und direkt warte.
Okay, bilirubin ist erhöht. Was machen Sie noch? Was kontrollieren Sie noch im Blut?
Und CRP und Blutzenkungsgeschwindigkeit.
CRP ist gut, Blutzenkungen muss man nicht unbedingt machen, aber was ist mit den Leberwerten?
Und ja, Alkalernphosphatase und Jamagotamin Transkalent.
Das sind die sogenannten Schollestase-Parameter, Bilirubin, direkt indirekt, alkalische Phosphatase,
GOT, GPT oder ALT, ALST.
Man kann noch die Lipase mitmachen zusätzlich.
Dann hat man alles komplett, um zu gucken, ob was in der Bauspeicheldrüse ist.
Wichtig ist hier aber auch die Gerinnung mitzumachen, die Rinnungswerte.
Ob da ein Problem schon an der Gerinnung ist, wenn der zum Beispiel eine Tombocytopenie hat,
das zeigt ein Leber-Zell-Schaden, kann man aber auch an GOT und GPT einsehen.
Wichtig ist auch die Gamma-GT, die habe ich vergessen zu sagen. Die Gamma-GT ist auch wichtig.
Okay, Sie nehmen den Patienten Blut ab, was machen Sie noch so?
Schicken wir dann wieder nach Hause, oder was machen wir?
Nein, ich glaube, der Patient soll als herbleiben.
Was machen Sie noch in der Ambulanz? Was kann man noch machen? Ganz schnell?
Bauch-Ultraschall.
Bauch-Ultraschall, ganz genau. Und was gucken Sie sich da besonders an?
Ja, ob der Patient schon in den Kolelithiasis oder in der Kolelithiasis hat.
Ja, genau. Ob er eine Schullezistolithiasis hat, ob er eine Schulle docholithiasis hat,
ob er Lebermetastasen hat, ob er eine Leberzirose hat, ob er eine Leberstauung hat,
ob er einen Pankreaskopfkarzinom hat, müssen Sie den DHC mit beurteilen.
Es gibt verschiedene Differenzialdiagnosen, bei Iterus.
Ganz viele, und die muss man dann abklären. Nennen Sie doch mal, bitte, einfach mal,
fünf Differenzialdiagnosen, nennen Sie mal welche.
Ja, Kolelithiasis und ja, Pankreaskopfkarzinom.
Ja, Lebersterose oder Leberstau.
Ja, eines auch was Infektioses sein, eines einer Hepatitis sein.
Ja, bei der Rheininfektion.
Hepatitis, man kann sein.
Ja, Rheininfektion von Hepatism.
Was müssen Sie bei diesen Patienten sagen, wenn man, Sie haben jetzt das Ultraschall gemacht,
das geht ganz schnell, Sie haben die Laborrate bekommen, im Ultraschall sehen Sie nichts.
Ja, nichts. Ja, ist alles in Ordnung, beispielsweise.
Ja, und, was müssen Sie bei den Patienten differenzialdiagnostisch noch in Betracht ziehen,
warum er diesen Iterus haben könnte, aufgrund seiner Anamnese?
Ja, wenn ich bei der Ultraschalluntersuchung, ob man Ultraschalluntersuch und Obdaphyl kann,
gefunden habe, dann ja, die.
Nein, meine Frage ist an einem Nestig, Sie haben ihn befragt, er hat ihn geantwortet,
er hat ihm Informationen gegeben und warum könnte er doch ein Iterus haben,
obwohl wir im Ultraschall nichts sehen.
Was könnte der Grund für den Iterus oder für das Leberversagen sein?
Er nimmt ja eine Reihe von Medikamenten ein, haben Sie mal die Medikamente sich angeschaut?
Er nimmt NSA, ja, er nimmt Paratetamol ein, er nimmt Atomastatine ein, er nimmt Zetraline ein.
Was sind alles Medikamente, die zusammen auf die Leber schlagen können?
Müssen nicht können, aber, ne?
Richtig.
Müssen Sie immer, wenn Sie eine Anamnese machen,
Sie müssen immer mit Tradenken.
Es muss nicht immer organisch sein, es kann auch durch Medikamente für Ursacht sein,
Iatrogen für Ursacht sein.
Ja? Okay, ich gehe noch mal auf das Ultraschall ein,
worauf gucken Sie auch, nicht nur auf die Leber,
sondern auch auf das Pankreis, auf die Galmblase,
worauf schauen Sie noch, ob es ein Leberversagen oder ein Fortgeschrecknis-Leberversagen sein könnte.
Was suchen Sie im Bauchraum?
Acid zum Beispiel, ne?
Kann man auch im Bauchraum schon sehen für ein Fortgeschrecknis-Leberversagen zum Beispiel, ne?
Was können Sie noch in der Bildgebung machen?
Also nicht heute, sondern morgen vielleicht.
Das haben Sie schon erwähnt, eben bei der Anamnese.
Und ja, RCP und MRCP auch.
Ein Beispiel kann man machen, ne?
Muss man aber nicht sofort machen, eigentlich.
Ultraschall ist das A und O, ne?
Man kann eine Magischpiegelung mit einer Endosonographie machen, ne?
Endosonographie kann man im Rahmen einer Magischpiegelung des Pankreis,
die Leber mit Beurteilen.
Oft kann man ja im Ultraschall den Pankreis nicht gut sehen,
weil es Luft überlagert ist, ne?
So viel Luft über das Pankreis,
oder wenn Sie Unterfahre sind mit Ultraschall,
und Sie können Ultraschall nicht gut,
dann ist immer gut, wenn ein erfahrene Arzt am nächsten Tag
eventuell eine Endosonographie macht, ne?
So ein ganz einfaches Verfahren, eigentlich.
Alternativ können Sie natürlich auch einfach ein MRT machen.
MRT-Abdomen geht auch, ne?
Aber können Sie natürlich nicht Sonntags machen,
sollen Sie am nächsten Tag machen, oder?
Okay.
Können Sie das bestätigen?
Man sieht diese Mathe unter so, Matheabdomen.
Das können Sie sonntags schwierig machen,
ja, wenn es kein akuter Fall ist,
dann macht man das nächsten Tag oder danach den Tag.
Es ist ja jetzt nichts, was akut ist.
Er hat das schon seit fünf Tagen, ne?
Sie müssen nur um Ultraschall schauen,
ob er eine Abflussstörung hat,
oder ob er eine erhöhten Zündungswert hat,
ob man direkt Appel verschaffen muss, ne?
Wenn man dann Stein wegnehmen muss, zum Beispiel,
wer blockiert, ne?
Wenn die Gallenfluss im Behindert sein sollte.
Das müssen Sie nur in der Akutphase einmal sehen,
und dann kann man das, kann man agieren, ne?
Man sollte dem Patienten gegebenenfalls auch Antibiotikum geben,
muss man aber nicht immer machen.
Kann man machen, muss man nicht machen, ne?
Okay.
Kennen Sie es so mit...
Kennen Sie es so? Ja?
Fragen Sie mal.
Tschuldigung, was?
Kennen Sie es sich?
Kennen Sie es sich mit Ektirus aus?
Kennen Sie die?
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Ektirus kann ja auch vom Herzen kommen, ne?
Ja, das kann sein.
Ein Ende zum Beispiel.
Haben Sie den Patienten gefragt, ob er Unterschenkel-UD-Mas hat?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Es kann sein, dass er auch Unterschenkel-UD-Mas
rechtser Erzversagen hat, zum Beispiel, ne?
Dann kann es auch sein,
dass er einen eventuellen,
eine Stauungsleber hat.
Das kann auch sein, ne?
Muss man immer mit dran denken.
Das ist nicht nur unbedingt immer das Geleber.
Bei Ektirus muss man global denken.
Man muss dann alles denken.
Man darf nicht so sagen, er hat auf jeden Fall Krebs.
Sie haben Krebs, Sie haben ein Karzinom,
Sie werden sterben, das geht nicht.
Sie müssen gucken, ob das ganzheitlich betrachtet.
Ja, richtig.
Deswegen habe ich gefragt, Sie müssten immer
mehrere Differenzialdiagnosen.
Er kann auch eine Hämolise haben, ne?
Wenn er jetzt, wenn er seit Videorubin
direkt indirekt geschaut haben,
gleich hat er ein Lymphom, ne?
Zum Beispiel, er hat eine Autoimmunhämolise, zum Beispiel.
Es gibt viele Differenzialdiagnosen,
die wir jetzt hier nicht sprechen können,
aber die Sie nochmal nachlesen sollten.
Das ist ein großes Thema, Ektirus.
Welche Therapievorschläge?
Mein Therapie wäre, erstmal die Medikamente abzusetzen.
Also Ibuprofen, alles absetzen.
Und dann Ultraschall machen,
wenn wir im Ultraschall nichts Gravierendes gesehen haben,
also kein Stein, zum Beispiel,
wir haben keine Lieberzerose gesehen oder dergleichen.
Erst mal alles absetzen,
Kontrolle am nächsten Tag der Laborwerte,
ob die steigen oder nicht steigen
oder zwei Tage später,
er hat ja keine Schmerzen.
Aber was wir machen sollten,
wäre auf jeden Fall zu schauen,
ob er ein Pankreaskopkarzinom hat.
Das kann man sehr schwer in der Ambulanz sehen,
oft kann man nur sehen,
wenn man eine Abflussstörung auch sehen kann,
wenn der DHC komprimiert wird,
Induktus empathicus.
Und ich habe jetzt diesen Fall etwas schwierig dargestellt,
es könnte alles sein,
es könnten Medikamente sein,
es könnte ein Tumor sein,
es könnte ein Stein sein, es könnte alles sein.
Es kommt immer auf das Labor an.
Wenn er erhöhte Entzündungszeichen hat,
zum Beispiel als CHP-Erhöhung, als Fieber,
als Schüttelfrost,
dann sollte man einen Antibiotipen geben, auf jeden Fall.
Damit man eine Scholle angeht, ist vermeidet zum Beispiel.
Und man sollte alles Hepatotoxisches weglassen.
Diese Medikamente sind alle Hepatotoxisch.
Die muss man alle weglassen und schauen,
wie sich der Patient entwickelt.
Der Patient hat ja auch gesagt,
er hat das Atovostatin erst seit einigen Monaten bekommen,
sehr trahlien auch,
und er hat in der letzten Zeit vermehrt zusätzlich
zum Ibuprofen Paratitamol eingenommen.
Das Weitere trinkt regelmäßig Alkohol am Wochenende.
Am Wochenende.
Er hat einiges.
Also dieser Patient muss kommen,
dieser Patient muss komplett überarbeitet werden.
Konische Hepatitis,
welche Symptome haben wir ja gesehen?
Konische Hepatitis?
Ja.
Keine.
Diese Patienten ...
Also eine Konische Hepatitis macht in der Regel
keine Beschwerden, wenn sie nicht fortgeschritten ist.
Die meisten Patienten wissen aber,
dass sie eine chronische Hepatitis haben,
weil es halt chronisch ist, schon länger andauert.
Die meisten sind noch in Behandlung,
Kontrolle zum Beispiel.
Auch wenn sie nur Träger von der Hepatitis B sind,
müssten sie regelmäßig kontrolliert werden.
Sie müssten auch, wenn sie jetzt nicht Träger,
sondern eine aktive chronische Hepatitis haben,
dann müssten sie normalerweise jede sechs Monate,
mindestens jedes Jahr,
einmal die Viruslast bestimmt bekommen.
Entweder vom Hausarzt oder von den Hepatologen
oder Gastryntologen.
Und sie müssten jedes Jahr ein Ultraschaller bekommen,
ob eventuell eine Fibrosis schon besteht.
Eine sogenannte Elastiziz-Sonografie nennt sich das,
um die Steilbarkeit der Leber zu messen.
Aber dieser Patient hatte ja keine chronische Hepatitis.
Er hat eigentlich nur Rückenschmerzen
und eine Depression mit Angststörungen
und seine Cholesterin-Erhöhung
und Alkoholkonsum.
Bevor wir eine Diagnostellung
sollen wir Welchertherapie
anfordern.
Ich würde erstmal,
Therapie würde ich erstmal Flüssigkeit zuvor machen
und je nach Labor, wenn er eine Zündung hat,
muss man Antibiotikum geben natürlich.
Wenn er ansonsten kann, kann man erstmal nichts machen
in der Ambulanz. Man muss erstmal wissen, was er hat.
Deswegen hat Herr Lale, als der Patient gefragt hat,
Was habe ich denn?
Er konnte nicht genau antworten.
Er hat gesagt, es kann das sein, das sein.
Ich würde an ihrer Stelle sagen,
Sie haben wahrscheinlich eine Leber
versagt, warum wissen wir aber noch nicht zum Beispiel?
Sie können aber auch sagen, es kann eine Bellerabflussstörung sein.
Wenn der Patient sie fragt, habe ich Lebertrebs,
dann haben sie gesagt, ja, könnte sein.
Das würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Das würde ich überhaupt nicht sagen,
weil dann machen sie den Patienten sehr unzufrieden,
sehr traurig.
Er ist echt undepressiv, hat eine Angststörung.
Dann machen sie ihn noch nicht.
Er ist noch unruhiger, als er eh schon ist.
Ich würde gar nichts in der Ambulanz mit Krebs sagen.
Überhaupt nichts.
Sie müssen sagen, wir müssen erst Untersuchungen machen
und um diese Diagnose zu stellen, ist viel zu früh.
Auch wenn er sagt, könnte ich Krebs haben,
das bezweifle ich erstmal.
Wir müssen erst andere Ursachen ausschließen.
Das ist mit Krebs gar nichts in der Ambulanz zu sagen.
Es sei dann bekannt, wenn der Patient zu ihm kommt
und sagt, ich habe ein bekanntes HCC,
also ich habe einen bekannten Lebertumor,
dann ist es etwas anderes.
Dann kann man natürlich darüber sprechen.
Aber Krebserkrankungen,
eher Notaufnahme zu besprechen,
das ist ungünstig.
Sollte man lieber ruhig auf Station
oder sogar mit dem Oberat zusammengegeben, falls man es macht.
Gibt es irgendwelche Fragen zu diesem Thema?
Sie können alles alle Fragen stellen, die Sie möchten.
Ich habe jeden Fall ein bisschen schwierig dargestellt.
Der Patient hat ja alles gehabt.
Der hat Lebertoxische Medikamente,
der Buritus, der hat Geld, Dunkelverfärbungen.
Oft haben die Patienten aber nicht alles zusammen.
Die haben meistens nur eine Sache.
Von daher ist es oft auch einfacher.
Mir ging es hier nur darum,
dass Sie wissen oder sich überlegen sollten,
dass das Thema Ictorus ein komplexes Thema ist.
Es ist nicht wie Herzinfarkt,
das ist Herzinfarkt, da geht das fertig.
Das ist nicht so Ictorus, es ist komplizierter manchmal.
Erst mal, mein Kollegen, Sie haben meinen Namen Krebs.
Wir sollen vor und nach eine Frage.
Peter Krebs.
Nachher ist auch schon Krebs.
Der Patient hat gesagt, knapp 80 kg,
aber danach 80 kg.
Was bedeutet knapp 80 kg?
knapp 80 ist entweder 81 oder 79 kg.
Einige Tage, welche Sivischen-Tage?
Da muss man genau nachfragen.
Bei manchen Patienten heißt einige Tage 3 Tage, 2 Tage.
Bei manchen Patienten heißt einige Tage 3 Wochen.
Da muss man selber nachfragen.
Was meinen Sie mit einigen Tagen?
Meinen Sie Tage oder Wochen oder Monate?
Das müssen Sie aktiv selbst nachfragen.
Aber meistens sind das 5 Tage, würde ich sagen.
Der Patient hat gesagt, keine Fieber, keine Neuseherbrichtung.
Wir müssen fragen, ob Ihre Fieber einmal gemessen hat.
Richtig, genau.
Haben Sie Fieber überhaupt gemessen?
Manche Patienten sagen auch, ich habe viel bei ich bin krank.
Dann fragen Sie, wie viel Kraft haben Sie gemessen?
Ich habe gar nicht gemessen, ich habe nur gefühlt.
Das müssen Sie genau erfragen.
Was?